again going back to this idea that
war reveals human nature
and and this is dr frankel's way of
putting this
exact same thing that i say back to the
book life in a concentration camp tore
open the human soul and exposed its
depths
it is is it surprising
that in those depths we again found only
human qualities which
in their very nature were a mixture
of good and evil
the rift dividing good from evil which
goes through
all human beings reaches into the lowest
depths
and becomes apparent even on the bottom
of the abyss
which is laid open by the concentration
camp
so we've got this idea once again that
there's a dichotomy in people
in people this dichotomy that you're
capable of doing
extreme good and you're capable of doing
extreme evil and we've seen it a bunch
we've seen it a bunch on this podcast
but you look at the meli massacre those
guys
were normal guys that committed
extreme evil straight up evil
normal guys that were you know
four days earlier probably would have
done something heroic to save
someone and here they are the other end
of the spectrum
and i think that you have to we have to
face that not only individually
do you have that but then obviously as
the group you have that
as a group of human beings we have that
capability we've seen it over and over
again
and if you want to know what that good
part is you got to know what that
darkness is too
yeah yeah the group thing
is interesting like you know you know
how you always hear not always but you
hear
sometimes about these riots on college
campuses
whether it be after a game or something
like that
bro at a glance you'd think dang is this
college full of full of just hooligans
like if this bit like huge riots you
know
but it's that it's like as an individual
or you know under quote unquote normal
circumstances they just they're just
normal people
you know guys girls whatever they're
just normal people
but then you put them in this particular
situation in some way extreme
or whatever you know it's a spectrum but
and they just act different
and the whole group dynamic too they'll
just act different the group dynamic is
a uh
is it can be a very very scary thing
man there's no doubt it can be a very
very scary thing and that's
that's why you know even when he's
talking about and i mentioned this on
when i was on joe rogan's last podcast
i'm like this the idea of individual
freedom
and acting as an individual is so
important
as to to structure your life around to
say look i'm not part of this
group this group is not me yeah this
group is not me they don't represent
me i represent me exactly and i'm
i have my own individual choices and
that's what he's saying in here
the minute you give away to the herd
yeah
that's when you start going you don't
know you you no longer control it
yeah and when you give up that control
that's a scary scary thing and that's
when these evil
things take place yeah and that
once again that's it's it's like it's
easy to say now
because grouping yourself is actually a
survival mechanism
true so you you know it's not going to
be just that
you're not going to naturally just be an
individual and act like an individual
and conduct yourself in all these
extreme situations
as an individual you're not just going
to naturally do that so
i guess it just helps to know these
things well that's you're you're
a hundred percent right on both facets
number one yes
grouping and fitting in is a survival
instinct that people have and
that's why trends happen and that's why
nations happen
and that's why that's why groups occur
in people
and politics yeah and politics and
everything right to get these groups and
i mean
it's weird now because with the internet
you can have groups you can be part of
these groups
anonymously
but it's also important to make sure
that you
you do remember that you
are an individual that you can that you
don't want to give up that last
shred of human will yeah to decide
what your attitude is going to be yeah
dang and
today you know in our luxurious society
if you can
consciously navigate your way clear that
of of
falling into the group trap it's what it
is it's a trap because you don't have to
if you can do that successfully but you
won't fall for the tricks man
like that's the thing you get we all get
tricked all the way down to just
something as
is seemingly benign as marketing
just man you'll just fall for way less
tricks
you don't like those tricks out there in
the world do you no
i don't probably fell for too many of
them i think